Rick ross. Guy Max was going to come
in, but he wouldn't do it on camera.
It was weird like he wouldn't
do it after he wanted to do it.
They'll do it at a certain time of
night, but here's the thing, man.
Some of that shit is publicists because
I'll tell you the same thing happened
with Liz Phair who I'm a
giant fan of hundred percent.
I've been a fan of Liz Phair for ed
to an exile in Guyville was fucking
fantastic.
Leverage record and evil empire at
the same time at the record store in
Nashville, Tennessee. That Reggie gets
machine and Exxon guy. Wow. Totally.
My wife also miss Dee who we
went near with who was listing,
she loved this fair too at the time she,
she came and we got high together.
She's like, you can get high here.
I'm like, yeah, I don't have a boss.
Alex Jones got high as fuck on high.
That was fucking awesome.
He's trying to come back on and I just
don't know if I could do it. Oh, come on.
Let them come on their fucking
stop dumping them down.
They are shutting them down.
But the problem is he still on trial this,
this whole trial that's going on with the
Sandy Hook and all that shit has to be
resolved first. But it doesn't mean
like Bill Maher respect to Bill Maher.
I respect him for saying he gets to
speak to [inaudible] was on his show and
people were clapping and cheering that
he was pulled off of these networks and
pulled off of everything. It's like, look,
this guy said crazy lies about
me is with Bill Maher said,
he said the guy said crazy lies about me.
He goes,
but he still gets to talk like
this is what America is about.
Free speech means all speech. But see
like, here's what I don't understand.
Like Alex had me on many times
and he supported my record.
Black ribbon sort of Cameron. Yeah. He
been on the Alex Jones show many times.
I've been, I've been on it
three times. Where you ever
sober? Yeah. Every time. Yeah.
Every time sober. I've never, I was never
a situation. Well, the first time I was,
uh, we have the black ribbons record that
I did as Steven King on and stuff like,
so when that record came out, nobody
would support the record. So Alex,
Stephen King's on your record,
old record from what I do,
he plays,
he plays a DJ or a radio talk show hosts
that comes in and out of the record.
Um, that Stephen King,
yeah, as Stephen King.
So like when I did that record,
Alex Jones is the only person that
would support the record. He put it, he,
he debuted the whole record
on his show and then I went,
it was on for two hours by phone and
then I went in and was on his show in
person, uh, about just the music business.
That's all we were talking about,
like kind of how things were.
And then later I was on for
bitcoin discussion kind of, um,
by Skype or something. But I will say
this in his defense, in all of this,
I just think that like,
dude,
that guy has been saying things and
conspiracy theories about all kinds of
things. What do you want?
Call him that or not.
But like forever and like now the,
the situation is like so
volatile that like they're gonna,
you know, the sandy hook thing. All right.
So like they definitely caught fucking
Anderson Cooper having the green screen.
And it's probably because they had another
person. They're talking to the mom.
And then what happened?
There's a video of Anderson interviewing
one of the moms from Sandy Hook and he,
he walked, he leans a little too
far forward and his nose disappears.
And it's probably because they had a
stand in reporter talking to the mom and
what Anderson Cooper was then
like, uh, put in via, you know,
whatever greenscreen and like kind of
I need to see it. Is there, I mean,
I know this is, we're, we're propelling,
but my point is, is like, and I'm not,
I mean,
Sandy Hook,
I remember where I was when I heard
about sandy hook and it was horrific.
And I don't believe for a
second that there's like,
it's all fake or anything like that.
But like Alex's thing has always been
that I remember watching him go to
Bohemian Grove when we
did the fucking record on,
this is back when nobody was
paying attention to them.
It just certain small group.
But I remember we did the black ribbons
record and we took a clip of the
laughing.
He went,
he snuck into Bohemian Grove and film
the ceremony and there's like a scene
where they were not a scene.
I get the scene in his film,
but there's a part of that where they're
doing the ceremony and they have this
light. It's like Disneyland when you
go well look, the owl God. Yeah, yeah.
But it's like it's done in a way where
it's like Disneyland when you watch like
the ferries fly around the castle.
Like there was a whole thing where there
was like a laugh that happens at the
end of the Moloch thing or whatever.
Or the big owl and the, and the,
the funeral guys drove. So druids,
right. So like I used a part of that,
but I remember watching that
documentary and he, you know,
his deal has always been so over the
top where like you go, he's like,
where are the, he like go to the local
people aren't near Bohemian Grove.
He's like, we're looking for
where the Satan, it's go to
go do that. Then you know,
and it's obviously at this point, it's
not like people who are knowingly sadness.
It's like really old fat rich guys that
go there and there's probably hookers
and all kinds of shit because that's
what happens at big rich things,
especially in the nineties I mean,
so he get away with it. Right.
And so like now with all this and they're
crucifying him, especially pointing,
especially the Megan Kelly thing.
And I just feel bad for it. I mean,
especially the Magna Kelly,
because that was clearly a headpiece
with Alex because like they,
she buddied up to him and then then
focus that piece on the sandy hook thing.
You know, they had their talk in
her defense, how could she not?
Of course she's got on if you're going
to come Jones, if I was going to come.
But if I came here with the,
with the intention of like just talking
to you and then all of a sudden you were
like, hey, on this day on this
thing, when you did the thing,
like you focused on this one
thing, now it'd be like, Oh man,
like this is a hit piece. Like,
yeah, but you're a musician and he's,
this is what he does. I know Alex is my
friend. He's been my friend since 1999.
I get more shit from being friends
with Alex Jones and anything in my life
because you know what I'm just saying
like, I'm sure I'll get hit for this,
but the point is, is that point in check
her Twitter, I'm ready for it. I don't,
you know what, I don't have to check
it maybe next year, but like, um,
but the reality is I just think that,
and I'm not even here from
like the side of the, the,
the political point of view is this,
it watch this video, this is the video.
It says d quality Anderson
Cooper's disappearing,
knows Greenstein clip debunked. I see
that. Hold on. Do you see what it says?
It says debunked,
which means they had let us down there.
Hold on, let him, sorry. Bad
quality video right here.
It'll play about three seconds.
Then there's a it,
there's a weird part on his nose that
happens, but just say it's a green screen.
I would just,
I would tell the same,
the same people that are looking
for conspiracies and everything.
They use this to say that the
space station didn't exist. Right,
but hold on right around right there.
Hold on and you can't even really see it.
Something really happened to those
super quick that looks like it was.
It was just like a digital glitch.
That's it. No, that's not it.
This is what I couldn't find it anywhere.
You've seen the other piece. Yeah.
I mean he leans forward his
nose. Look, here's what I think.
I think that they had a stand in because
he couldn't be there, but hold on.
You might be wrong. I could be. This is,
we're talking about several years ago.
You might have a fucked up memory.
This,
let's try to find the video that said
he was there all week shooting from the
exact same location. Maybe it
was, maybe I'm wrong. Got You.
They got to you shooter Jennings.
I would say the same thing.
You know, so you make more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year. Dude,
knocks on your door and starts
talking to you about conspiracy.
Well, if you make it $34,000 a year, you
look at people to make 100,000 like Tam,
all my fucking bills. How do you get to
that hundred thousand dollar level? Well,
you got to sell out, son.
That's how people look at it.
But there is a threshold. There is a
threshold. I remember when I was broke,
I had an a suburban. I wasn't broke,
but it was, I was doing it right,
but I had a suburban and some guy and I
got into a fucking road rage situation
on the highway and he goes,
you fucking rich asshole. I go,
rich Mike.
I'm trying to fucking suburban man.
Like what is rich to you?
Rich is driving a suburban
man.
I have that.
Like I already had the rich thing because
people thought that I was rich because
my dad, which I never really, I never
was. I mean he was supportive of me,
but once I got here it was, I was Kinda
on my own. I liked that. But then,
then once I talk about bitcoin with you,
like fucking five years ago or whenever
it was, I was here three years ago.
Everyone's like, oh, you gotta
be rich now. Cause that I'm like,
I can not reject coin.
Yeah.
But I mean look what's all the point
up to like seven grand now. Yeah.
Went up to 1930 seconds.
Keep going down sick.
He hadn't dropped very much
below six grand. But I mean,
when I was here with you,
it was like less than a grant.
But um,
you know what I'm trying to say about
this is not like I'm not validating his,
this Anderson Cooper thing,
but that dude has always been
fishing for things like that.
And it's always been his gig and
it's been as Gig from Columbine.
It's been as Gig from all of this,
and I understand the,
the passion and the emotion involved with
the children that died in sandy hook.
And I have no, I'm not defending him
on that deal, but at the same time,
that's always been this guy's Gig.
I feel like dad is where he legitimately
fucked up. I don't think if you take,
you take away, I got to defend
him to fucking fuck up. Yeah.
But this is a silly fuck up.
He's saying that for sure it was a fake,
but did he say for sure it's a,
hey did people sent me the clip?
They sent me a clip of him saying that
it was 100% fake. He thought it was fake.
So he said it, but he thought it
was fake. Yeah, he thought it was a,
he thought it was a false flag. So
he said it. I mean, but that's part,
that's a part of the conspiratorial
thinking. That's a real problem.
It's like saying, you know,
he said some shit about me.
He said send him some shit
about me and it's 100% not true.
He said that post your interview
with them. I don't remember.
I think it was post,
it was post.
He said that the government threatened
my family to stop talking about
conspiracy theories. No, no.
Nobody threatened my family.
No one zero never happened.
Did Not happen. It is fake.
It is a lie. Someone told it to him, I
guess, or he says someone told it to him.
It didn't happen. There's
so, that's me. I understand.
But he didn't understand
like how frustrating that
is. This is a minor thing.
Someone him lying, not lying. Okay.
Some he said someone told him,
I believe he's telling the truth,
but it's not true. He could have fucking
called me. He's got my number man.
Call me.
So he didn't even bother calling me Joe.
I'm about to go live from Austin,
Texas.
I need to know did someone
threaten your family?
Stop talking about the moon landing and
big foot sturgeon to fucking imagine
they're gonna threaten you.
You got to stop talking about
big foot man. Like, well,
no, I, I found, I did a show.
This is a well documented,
I've talked about it a
hundred times in the podcast.
I did a show called Joe Rogan questions
everything and during that show over a
period of six months I fucking
questioned a lot of shit legitimately,
but I did it with researchers. We
had the staff, we had producers,
we went and we,
we actually went to like these places
where these people are claiming to see
you.
Fo's went to these places where
people are claiming to be able to uh,
what does that shit they do? Remote
viewing, remote view. Oh yeah.
We talked to those great movie.
We talked to all these
people and I found a real,
a clear thread through all of it that
I documented in my 2014 comedy central
special where I said,
here's what you don't find.
When you go looking for
bigfoot black people,
what you do find is
unfuckable white dudes,
you are more likely define big foot.
Then you are black people out looking
for big, full wholesale alien abductions.
Probably it's due to,
and they go looking for hidden mysteries.
This is a real big part of it. I know.
I know. My point is from doing that.
Show it,
it's soured me off conspiracy theories.
Conspiracy theories were fun for me and
me and my, and especially Eddie Bravo,
me and Eddie Bravo would get high and
we'd watched documentaries on flying rods
and all this UFO documentaries
and all the other, the the,
the fucking Zachariah sitch and shove
it. And I love that. I love that stuff.
But here's the thing,
I used to watch a,
a chariots of the gods all the time to
get it all falls apart under scrutiny.
It all of it all means does all the girls.
It's fun but it falls apart if
you're being a serious person.
And if you really being honest about what
you actually know, this is the problem.
It's like the saint and the parallels
like that comparison comparing to Alex
Jones, saying that my family was
threatened. It's the same thing.
My family was never threatened.
No one ever threatened me. So,
but he's saying this on the radio.
Why is he saying it?
Because someone told him and he may be,
he believes it and he also
thinks it's fun to say.
It's the thing to say if you're
really into conspiracies,
but this is the problem with
these fucking conspiracies.
They say things they don't
know are true and they say,
I'm like they're true now this is fine.
If you just that hold on,
it's fine if it's not an issue.
If you're talking about the Illuminati,
if you talking about your kid getting
shot, if your kid's dead and someone says,
hey man, this fucking Tom Smith on
the radio saying you're full of Shit.
You're a crisis actor and your kid's not
dead. I mean you're crying every night.
You wake up in the middle of night
crying because some fucking guy,
I'm that you are a little bit, I'm just
discussing this right to be Alex Jones.
I and I defend that as well.
And then when bill for being David,
I'll coat one time I would
have David Allen Coe do.
I played a show with David Allan Coe went,
this is not any like,
let's get sandy hook out of this
cause I'm not trying to talk,
let's make some defending the
right of people to be who they are.
And I love David Alinka
is music and all that.
But I played a show with David Onco one
time and my dad always would tell me
these things about him. You know, he, he
really, he liked David and everything,
but there was always kind of
a little distance of like,
there was a showmanship part of him and
were like a good example of this. Again,
distancing from Sandy Hook.
But a good part of it was that when,
when David Allen Coe,
we did a show with him one time.
My mom was over on the side of the
stage with me. I was opening for him.
This is many years ago before I even
had a first record out or anything. Um,
and David Allen Coe did sh, you
know, we did our song, our set,
and then he played and he was onstage
and he performed a song my mom wrote
called storms.
Never last,
so my mom's over on the side of the
stage and we were talking and my mom are
watching it and he's singing
it with his wife and stuff.
The next night I'm opening up for
him and he goes on stage and he goes,
last night,
Jesse culture was right in the front row
when I sang the song with my wife and
she was crying and like
I'm sitting there going,
I was here and she was not crying.
She was standing there.
She called and she was not on
the front row. Right, right.
My mom just colder wrote the song
storms never last teasing and,
and that's his character.
That's who he is.
All I'm saying here with like I'm as
forgiving about him lying to the audience
because that is what he's
doing at the moment. It's
his. I could sit there and go,
you know what? You're lying. I'm
going to take you in the back.
We're going to talk. I'm going to tell
this audience tomorrow night. He's a liar.
He's a piece of shit. Fuck him. I'm not
going to do that because it's David Alco.
He's, you just sit it on the show,
which is, I'm not much larger audience,
millions of pieces of shit.
I'm just saying the character,
but why would I do that to him? Because
it's like, you know, I just feel like,
look man, the Times that I met Alex at
times I've been around him. Yeah man,
his Gig is this and he got called
out for a specific thing. Yes.
It involves the lives of children and
everything that I understand that I'm not,
I'm not at all sympathizing for those
family or for him versus those families,
but I'm just saying,
I just think that like at the moment
everything is so hot with this and it's,
and it, it's kind of exhausting and it's
the Internet is the reason for it in my
opinion, because I think that like
all the years that have come along,
the mass amount of people that
have migrated to social media,
the way that the integrated
conversations happened,
the way that that stuff
ends up on the news now,
like AOL chat rooms in fucking 1998
that shit did not end up on CNN.
People were not listening
to those. The, the, the,
the best tank get the closest you
could get to fucking TV was to catch a
Predator when, when you were on
that, at that time, you know,
and I feel like at this point
in time, people need, again,
not those families. There are lawsuits.
That's fine. That's, that's their thing.
But, but I just feel like people need to
lighten up a little bit in the sense of,
uh, I just think that the social media
thing is very hazardous and I think that
people's faith in all of it, it doesn't
have to do with, with fake news.
And it doesn't have to do with
Russian bots and all this shit.
I just think that like Alex Jones is a
casual the, because he's always been that.